this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skillshare
believe it or not i actually was not
going to do another election lawsuit
video but
just when i think i'm out they pull me
back in just when i thought i was out
they pulled me back in and here there's
actually
so much hilarious stuff that's going on
that you'd never know if you've never
litigated in federal court before i was
going to say
you wouldn't know it if you hadn't
practiced at a high level in federal
court before but honestly even if you
practice at a low level in federal court
you'd know how crazy these shenanigans
are
because frankly when democracy is at
stake the only thing that you can do is
laugh
but i feel like it's incumbent upon me
to share the humor to explain why some
of the things that are happening
in these trump campaign lawsuits are so
particularly funny why
the trump lawyers are so so bad at this
and why they keep failing in spectacular
fashion
because so far they've been walking into
rakes and they will continue to walk
into rakes
[Music]
and at base these lawsuits are just
going down in flames they're either
being dismissed by the trump campaign
itself and not wanting to prosecute or
litigate these cases or
they're getting dismissed by the judges
and recently
we have some momentous decisions in
pennsylvania that seem to be a
bellwether for the rest of these cases
and other states are just simply
certifying the election results
regardless of the lawsuits and
it doesn't seem like these lawsuits are
going to change the results
and just because the lawsuits themselves
don't have any merit doesn't mean that
they can't also screw it up by
litigating them
poorly now today we're going to update
some of the lawsuits that we've
previously talked about
talk about some of the new lawsuits that
have been filed and a lot of the oral
argument that has taken place in various
filings that have been filed with the
federal courts
but first i'm afraid we have to start
with the insane
press conference that happened at the
rnc that was led by rudy giuliani and
sydney powell
two of president trump's remaining
lawyers now this was one of the wildest
press conferences
ever given on behalf of the president of
the united states and that includes the
one given
at the four seasons total landscaping
now you might have seen clips from this
press conference not only because
president trump tweeted out that this
was going to reveal a
path to victory but also because rudy
giuliani had a meltdown
on camera and i'm not saying that
metaphorically he appeared to literally
melt down
we're not exactly sure what happened to
rudy giuliani but it appears that
profuse sweating
mixed with some hair dye led to rivulets
of black liquid pouring down both sides
of his face
now people are wondering why rudy
giuliani would even bother to put hair
dye
on his remaining hair but i think this
sort of makes sense in a weird way
there's a theory of neuro-linguistics
that says that
if you adopt the vocal mannerisms of a
person that you're talking to and their
their physical characteristics then
they're more likely to agree with you
so if you are the lawyer for the man who
has the most famous bad hair job in
history
then it sort of makes sense that you
would do crazy things to your own hair i
it's really just good client management
and here is rudy talking about
and reenacting my cousin vinnie did you
all watch my cousin vinnie
did you know the movie it's one of my
favorite war movies
because he comes from brooklyn and when
the the nice lady
who said she saw and then he uh he says
to her how many
fingers do i how many fingers will i got
up
and she says uh three
well she was too far away to see it was
only two
these people were further away than my
cousin vinnie was from the witness
which good for rudy he does more or less
accurately recount that scene
in my cousin vinnie but it's hard not to
think of andy dwyer recounting his
favorite movies when you hear
rudy giuliani off on this weird tangent
about this particular movie
yes that's a long way of saying that
things that are further away
are harder to see and there are reports
that giuliani was enticed to come back
as the president's lawyer by being paid
twenty thousand dollars per day
so i would just like to say that if
anyone wants to pay me twenty thousand
dollars per day
i also know my cousin vinnie very very
well and i can
recite scenes from my cousin vinnie with
at least the kind of fidelity that rudy
giuliani has
eggs and grits i like grits too now i
think it's interesting to point out that
at this point in the litigation
president trump is not represented by
the lawyers that represented him
in the impeachment hearings people like
jay sekulow john dowd and ty cobb
now say what you will about those
particular lawyers they have an active
practice with a whole fleet of lawyers
that work for them and
they have certainly gotten results in
different contexts but
rudy giuliani it appears hasn't appeared
in federal court since
1992 but it's not just rudy giuliani
trump campaign lawyer sydney powell
blamed venezuela cuba
and likely china for trump's losses
massive
influence of communist money powell used
to be a reasonably respected lawyer but
recently she's gone full deep state
conspiracy tinfoil hat
and not for nothing she is also the
lawyer for mike flynn take that as you
will
but sidney powell's theory is that the
dominion voting machines used throughout
america were originally engineered by
hugo chavez to ensure that he never lost
an election
despite the fact that chavez has been
dead since 2013 and
hand recounts have confirmed that biden
beat trump in various states
and it would be easy to check the
electronic records against the physical
ballots but
don't let that get in the way of a great
conspiracy theory of course
rudy also dismissed the hand recount out
of hand by reenacting how the votes
could have been cast for mickey mouse or
a dead person or one person voting 30
times
that could have been mickey mouse all
these examples really happened he says
bereft of any evidence whatsoever and
jenna ellis the
third lawyer for the trump campaign in
this uh
conference explained that people asking
for evidence of these claims just don't
understand how the legal process works
your question is fundamentally flawed
when you're asking where is the evidence
what we have asked for
in the court is to not have the
certification
of false results and yeah fair enough
if you call a press conference you are
not obligated to provide the evidence
but
this press conference is not for the
court's benefit but for the public's
benefit and if you have the evidence you
might actually want to present that
evidence
both in the court of public opinion and
in the actual court but we've seen time
and time again that the trump campaign
is just simply
not reiterating these grand conspiracy
theories in
court where they have the potential to
be sanctioned and sidney powell went on
to claim without evidence that in the
middle of the night someone from
dominion came in and injected the votes
into
detroit well i'm talking about some
massive straight lines up
in the vote tallies in the middle of the
night after they've supposedly stopped
counting
and that's when the dominion operators
went in
and injected votes and changed the whole
system we've already seen effectively
zero discrepancies where there's a hand
count of uh
the dominion machines and interestingly
sydney powell
after this conference went on to claim
that georgia governor brian kemp
conspired with democrats
to win georgia for the presidency but
not the
senate seats and perhaps as a result of
these claims sydney powell was
effectively dismissed shortly thereafter
by jenna ellis via tweet
which can only be described as a public
knifing
it was pretty brutal to just publicly
disavow her after
weeks of saying that sidney powell is
the tip of the spear of this
trump campaign effort and just being
completely sidelined though
rudy giuliani has not been sidelined
which is uh interesting
this was a legal meltdown for all of the
trump campaign lawyers not just sidney
powell and
especially rudy giuliani so it's
interesting that he's staying on
and because everything is now a metaphor
to add insult to injury
or i suppose snot to hair dye
there's a point in this conference where
rudy sneezes into a handkerchief flips
the handkerchief over and then smears it
all over his face in an attempt to get
the hair dye
off that pretty much sums up this
conference in a nutshell
although the trump campaign legal team
has referred to themselves as an elite
strike force
this is an elite strike force team as
david farenhold said
they're more like the fire festival of
the legal world which is a great segue
into the actual cases themselves and one
of the cases in particular in
pennsylvania
gave rise to one of the most epic oral
arguments i've ever heard in my life
as well as one of the most interesting
decisions by the court which we'll get
to
both in a second but first i want to say
a debt of gratitude to mark elias and
his team at democracydocket.com
not only is mark and his team keeping
tabs on all the different election suits
but they're
often in the front lines litigating this
stuff in court democracy docket has been
a godsend in trying to keep track of all
of these different cases and there are a
lot of them
so if you were to go to
democracydocket.com and donate
i would definitely not blame you and i
think i'll go there myself
but as mark and his team are want to
point out at this point
the trump campaign and the trump
administration in court are about two
for 35
and the two that they've won are barely
wins they're more like participation
trophies so
it's not to say that these lawsuits
should not have been brought and that
they're good for democracy or anything
but
that is to say that they are losing
pretty spectacularly and that ratio is
unlikely to change and
they're unlikely to have any effect on
the results of the election whatsoever
[Music]
hey it is uh future devon and things
have been moving so
fast that in the time that it has taken
to put this video together things have
actually changed dramatically so first
of all
the trump campaign is more like 1 and 39
at this point they actually
lost one of their victories so you can
take one away from the win column and
now it is in the
loss column and there has been a very
very interesting appeal that has come
out which i will talk about
towards the end of the video so uh back
to prior devon
[Music]
but with that caveat let's get into the
pennsylvania case
it's one of the more consequential cases
and we've talked about it before
which is donald j trump for president
versus kelly buchvar
this started out as the case that
referred to poll watchers spelled
p-o-l-e
which you would expect for maybe a case
in new jersey but
not pennsylvania but this whole case is
a lesson
in basic civil procedure i could
probably teach an entire class
on civil procedure just using the
court's decision
in this case that came out just a couple
of days ago over the weekend
so quick summary of this case for
context here the trump campaign on
behalf of several voters sued the
pennsylvania secretary of state
kathy bukhvar they made two main claims
one related to curing ballots and the
other related to poll watchers
and on that basis effectively the trump
campaign sought to decertify the results
in pennsylvania or prevent the
certification from happening
now related to the curing of ballots
they claim that these two individual
voters had their votes disregarded and
that
different voters in the state based on
what county you are were able to
cure their ballots if they were
defective some counties
adopted a process where you could cure
the ballots in some counties is not
and these individuals lived in a county
where you couldn't cure those particular
ballots because they were
manifestly defective and then the second
was related to poll watchers
not being close enough now at this point
we're going to have to get into some
civil procedure but
trust me it will be worth it because
it's really incredibly interesting
because originally in this case the
trump campaign issued a
complaint which is the document that
starts the lawsuit it contains all of
your factual allegations the story of
what you say happens
the original complaint contained all
kinds of allegations of fraud
but you're allowed within certain time
frames to
amend your complaint and new lawyers
came on
and effectively they were adults in the
room removed all the allegations of
fraud for reasons we'll talk about in a
second
and then the trump campaign wanted to
reverse that and add the fraud
allegations
back now the timeline goes something
like this this lawsuit was filed on
november 9th by lawyers at porter right
which is a fairly well-regarded firm
which is probably why they left which
we'll get to
and another law office of linda kearns
now these lawyers filed the original
complaint but moved to withdraw just
four days later on november 13th
the judge allowed the porter right
lawyers to leave and then on november
15th
trump's new lawyers amended the
complaint and
some texas lawyers joined the case linda
kearns still represented trump at this
point and the amended complaint dropped
counts
three through seven of the original
complaint the ones that had all the
fraud in them
the judge scheduled a hearing on
november 17th and on november 16th just
one day after the lawyers filed the
amended complaint
the lawyers filed a motion to withdraw
from the case and a third set of lawyers
filed a motion to continue the hearing
because they had just joined which
under normal circumstances would
probably happen but when you're kind of
playing shenanigans the judge is
unlikely to
allow that kind of stuff and here the
judge denied this motion because there
were lawyers still on the case and you
can't just muck up the schedule because
you're
hiring and firing lawyers and on
november 17th the day of the hearing
rudy giuliani files a petition to appear
on behalf of the trump campaign
this was the fourth change in
representation in seven days
rudy then attends the hearing which
we'll get to because it's hilarious
and he also files the second amended
complaint but the federal rules of civil
procedure don't allow plaintiffs to
amend their complaints an unlimited
number of times you can't just
create a moving target to avoid
dismissal plaintiffs generally get one
amended complaint as a matter of right
within a certain number of days
and then subsequent amendments require
the leave of court required discretion
of the court to allow you to do it
nevertheless at the same time the
defendants were filing a motion to
dismiss to get rid of this case entirely
and
rudy and his team filed responses to
that motion to dismiss
that made new claims that were outside
the four corners of the first amendment
complaint
that there were a grand scheme to elect
joe biden and the voters were treated
unequally
i mean it's a whole mess which leads to
the oral argument
arguing this motion to dismiss rudy
giuliani was there to try to prevent the
court from
dismissing this case out of hand and
this oral argument was
one for the ages here rudy giuliani
had a hard time grasping what was in the
first amendment complaint what was
deleted
and what he was trying to add by
amending again
to add a second amended complaint so
here's rudy arguing that there was stuff
in the complaint that
simply wasn't there the only
clarification is
that we are going to seek leave we've
already prepared it
to amend this complaint to restore our
due process claims
which we think was mistakenly removed
well
but we're not but we're withdrawing
we're preserving for appeal the elector
and the elections caused
but we will not be proceeding on that
and some of this was in the deleted
second amended complaint but rudy
basically told the court my bad
it couldn't be helped changing of a lot
of lawyers shrug
emoji and there's a crucial part of this
oral argument where
rudy has a hard time distinguishing
whether he is alleging fraud in the
amended complaint or if he isn't
arguing fraud in the amended complaint
so it's correct to say that you're not
alleging fraud
in the amended complaint know your honor
he's not
because we incorporate by reference in
150
all of the allegations that preceded
which include a long explanation
of a fraudulent fraudulent process
a planned fraudulent process so you are
a lesbian fraud yes
and of course at other times he's
arguing the complete opposite does the
amendment complaint
lead fraud with particularity no you're
right
and and it doesn't plead fraud and the
reason that this is so important is
because that one of the rules of civil
procedure
rule 9b requires that if you allege
fraud you have to plead that with what's
called particularity normally when you
file a lawsuit you can just
file allegations on information and
belief that you think
this happened and this is called notice
pleading but
here if you allege fraud or mistake you
have to
allege the actual particularized facts
and you can't get away with just
pleading these weird nebulous claims so
if he is
actually arguing fraud then the standard
by which he has to plead his case
is much much higher and he obviously
doesn't want to do that
but rudy was often confused about what
he actually wanted throughout this
particular oral argument which takes me
to my favorite part of this particular
hearing
where rudy giuliani is trying to explain
the standard of law that applies now
remember for context that this is on a
motion to dismiss so the defendants have
filed a motion
for the court to just throw this case
out and when you file
such emotion generally speaking you have
to assume that
every factual allegation that the
plaintiffs have pled
is true so you're only looking at
whether it states a legal claim you're
not testing the sufficiency of
the factual allegations now there's some
nuance to that but that's
generally what's going on but at the
same time if you as a plaintiff are
arguing that a governmental law
is unconstitutional as they were here
then there's also a level of scrutiny
that the court must apply in terms of
determining whether this law
is unconstitutional or not so there's a
standard for the motion to dismiss and
then there's the standard
for examining whether the law itself is
constitutional or not
so that's the setup for what's happening
right here the judge asked rudy
what standard should be applied are you
arguing then that strict scrutiny should
apply
no the normal scrutiny should have
played with if if we had alleged fraud
yes but this is not a this is not a
fraud case and what you can hear is that
there's confusion the judge is talking
about the scrutiny that will be applied
to determining whether the pennsylvania
law is constitutional
rudy misunderstands and he thinks that
they're talking about the standard that
will apply to the motion to dismiss
which is why he says
normal scrutiny now that's not really a
thing but what he's saying
is that we should give the plaintiff the
benefit of the doubt
assume the factual allegations are true
and that's the standard on the motion to
dismiss
and it's not crazy that you would talk
about these two different standards it's
ships passing in the night that's
understandable but what we're about to
hear is totally inexcusable
the judge continues to talk about the
scrutiny the level of scrutiny towards
the pennsylvania law
and rudy just misses the mark entirely
why don't secretary butvars and the
counties satisfy
the standard review that you're talking
about it's not strict scrutiny
and it's the standard review you're
implying why don't their actions
satisfy this i thought that i'm
sorry i don't really understand the
question you're right well this this is
how i would look at it
i would think that it's it's a standard
review of strict scrutiny potential
you're not sure that that's the case i'm
not i'm not imposing my maybe i don't
maybe i don't understand what you mean
by stream
so here the judge is clearly talking
about how he should analyze the
pennsylvania law itself not the
standard on the motion to dismiss
generally there's three types of
scrutiny
when a court is analyzing a law for
constitutionality one is rational basis
review
which is how courts generally look at
laws it's assumed that as
long as the legislature has any rational
basis that law will be upheld
then there are certain times when you
use intermediate scrutiny and then
there's what's called
strict scrutiny where if you interfere
with a fundamental right
the court will almost always strike it
down it's
that's why it's called strict scrutiny
you're really scrutinizing that
particular law
and what's crazy about this is that as
the plaintiff
the trump campaign is saying that these
laws interfere with the voting rights
of people in pennsylvania so they want
strict
scrutiny to apply that makes it easier
to get this law disregarded and
disregard these particular votes
but rudy totally misses the mark and
doesn't argue
in favor of using strict scrutiny he has
no idea what he's talking about
and the difference between strict
scrutiny and rational basis review is
literally something that you learn
on the first day of law school and in
preparation for this i
actually looked at my law school notes
and that is a bit
of hyperbole in my class we didn't do
rational basis review versus strict
scrutiny until the second day of law
school so
it's a bit of hyperbole but not much now
after this hearing the trump campaign
said that rudy did a fantastic job and
that he clearly built up a rapport
with judge bran who was the judge here
in this particular case
because they were talking about what
restaurants to go to and making small
talk
but they changed their tune when the
judge issued his ruling
on saturday which i generally refrain
from going through
actual court decisions on this channel
but this decision
is very accessible and is a master class
in basic civil procedure
probably because this case was so
terrible in the first place but let's
start with a couple of different
excerpts from this particular case
starting with the introduction because
it does a great job of laying out what
the stakes are in this particular
litigation
in this action the trump campaign and
the individual plaintiffs seek to
discard millions of votes legally cast
by pennsylvanians from all corners
from greene county to pike county and
everywhere in between in other words
plaintiffs asked this court to
disenfranchise almost 7 million voters
this court has been unable to find any
case in which a plaintiff has sought
such a drastic remedy in the contest of
an election
in terms of sheer volume of votes asked
to be invalidated one might expect that
when seeking such a startling outcome a
plaintiff would come
formidably armed with compelling legal
arguments and factual proof of rampant
corruption
such that this court would have no
option but to regrettably grant the
proposed injunctive relief
despite the impact that it would have on
such a large group of citizens
this has not happened instead this court
has been presented with strained legal
arguments without merit and speculative
accusations unplead in the operative
complaint
and unsupported by evidence in the
united states of america this cannot
justify the disenfranchisement of a
single voter
let alone all the voters of its sixth
most populated state
our people laws and institutions demand
more at bottom
plaintiffs have failed to meet their
burden to state a claim upon which
relief may be granted therefore i grant
defendant's motion and dismiss
plaintiff's action with prejudice
and then the court goes into a great
summary of what actually happened
in this case here in 2019
pennsylvania allowed mail voting for all
of the people in pennsylvania
they allowed for various counties to
provide for curing of the ballots if
there was a defect
but in a prior case no counties were
required
to adopt a cure process so different
counties have different rules
and here the two plaintiffs were in
counties where they didn't have an
opportunity to cure their ballots and
they didn't cure their ballots
and then the court goes on to actually
analyze the legal merit of the
plaintiff's claims
stating that plaintiff's only remaining
claim alleges a violation of equal
protection
this claim like frankenstein's monster
has been haphazardly stitched together
from two distinct legal theories in an
attempt to avoid controlling precedent
the general thrust of this claim is that
it is unconstitutional for pennsylvania
to give states discretion
to adopt a notice and cure policy in
other words different counties have
different rules
and it goes on to state that the
plaintiffs are trying to mix and match
claims and bypass contrary precedent is
not
lost on the court and then the court
goes on to analyze the standing issue
and this is something that often gets
lost
in litigation but a plaintiff actually
has to have suffered an
injury you can't just go to court to get
an advisory opinion if you
haven't been personally wronged in a
legally cognizable way
and here the court goes on to say that
effectively
the their votes were rejected as were
the rules of those particular counties
and
different counties can have different
rules and that the trump campaign
is not a voter with a rejected vote at
all so
the trump campaign doesn't have uh
standing at all and then the court gets
to the heart of the equal protection
argument and because there's so much
misunderstanding about that
i think it's worth going over here
because the court summary is really
fantastic
the court says contrary to plaintiff's
assertions not all
unequal treatment requires court
intervention the equal protection clause
does not forbid classifications
it simply keeps governmental decision
makers from treating similarly situated
persons
differently the government could not
function if complete equality were
required in all situations
consequently a classification resulting
in some inequality
will be upheld unless it is based on an
inherently suspect characterization
or jeopardizes the exercise of a
fundamental right
so for example if you're a store
and you want to reject people who don't
have a shirt or shoes on
you can do that that's a classification
of people you're allowed to
prevent those people from shopping at
your store but you cannot
prevent people from shopping at your
store on the basis
that their skin color is different that
is a fundamental right
and it's a difference between people
that is
recognized as a inherently suspect
classification
so let's connect that concept with what
the plaintiffs alleged here regarding
their votes in being treated differently
and the court goes on to say here
because defendant's conduct
imposes no burden on individual
plaintiff's right to vote their equal
protection claim is subject to rational
basis review
going back to the scrutiny level
defendant counties by implementing a
notice and cure procedure have in fact
lifted a burden on the right to vote
even if
only for those who live in those
counties in other words
these plaintiffs are arguing that it's
not fair that people in
the other counties especially around
philadelphia
were allowed to cure their defective
votes when they lived in counties
that did not allow for a cure procedure
but that's not how that works
number one the people in those other
counties had a
restriction lifted and it's okay either
way a county can say
you're allowed to cure and a county can
also say you're not allowed to cure
but you can't argue that you were
injured because you didn't live in a
county that allowed you to cure
your ballot that's just craziness and
often the level of scrutiny that the
court applies is
the whole game if it's rational basis
reviewed the law is probably going to be
upheld
and if it's strict scrutiny the law will
probably be struck and the court goes on
to say individual plaintiff's claims
fail because it's perfectly rational for
a state to provide counties discretion
to notify voters
that they may cure procedurally
defective mail-in ballots
and the court goes on even assuming that
they can establish that their right to
vote had been denied which they cannot
plaintiffs seek to remedy the denial of
their votes by invalidating the votes of
millions of others
rather than requesting that their votes
be counted they seek to discredit scores
of other votes
but only for one race this is simply not
how the constitution works and the race
that
they're referring to is the presidential
race they want to
disregard the votes with respect to the
president but not the other down ballot
votes this is what the court refers to
as leveling down as opposed to leveling
up
if you leveled up you'd allow everyone's
vote to be counted or at least
cured but they are asking the court to
level down
everyone and disregard all of these
other votes that were made that were
allowed to be cured and then the court
goes on to say that
the allegations with respect to poll
watchers they didn't actually allege
that the republican poll watchers were
treated differently than the democratic
poll watchers so
there's no possible equal protection or
voting impropriety there
and then in the conclusion the court
says defendant's motion to dismiss the
first amendment complaint are granted
with prejudice
leave to amend is denied now i want to
point that out because there were a lot
of people
on the internet who pointed to the with
prejudice language as being particularly
significant
even really seasoned lawyers got this
one screwed up
what i will say is that the with
prejudice language
is really not unusual at all all that
means is that the court thinks that
allowing the plaintiff to add additional
factual allegations would be futile
there's
nothing that they can plausibly do to be
able to state an actual valid legal
claim
and so that's why the court is denying
leave to amend because there's nothing
that they can do
the claims are going to fail no matter
what and with prejudice simply means
that the decision is being made
on the merits of the case and that
there's
no leave to amend so with prejudice is
something that you see
in basically every civil case in the
entire world it
doesn't actually carry any more
significance other than this case is now
over at the trial court level they can
now appeal the decision
but it's it's over at the trial court
but it does appear that the trump
campaign is
going to appeal this particular decision
oh
it's devin from the future again and i
will tell you
i have seen some stuff but interestingly
since i am from the future i can tell
you that the trump campaign did in fact
file an appeal and the third circuit
court of appeals
heard the appeal in basically record
time and rejected they issued their
appeal even before i could get this
video out so i had to
reshoot this pickup but the court of
appeals basically said that
the trial court judge brand got this
decision exactly right and rejected the
trump campaign's appeal
stating free fair elections are the
lifeblood of our democracy
charges of unfairness are serious but
calling an election
unfair does not make it so charges
require specific allegations and then
proof
we have neither here and the court of
appeals actually calls out rudy giuliani
by name stating but as lawyer rudolph
giuliani stressed
the campaign doesn't plead fraud this is
not a fraud case
instead it objects that pennsylvania's
secretary of state and some counties
restrict
poll watchers and let voters fix
technical defects in their mail in
balance
it offers nothing more this case is not
about whether those claims are true
rather the campaign appeals on a very
narrow ground whether the district court
abused its discretion
in not letting the campaign amend its
complaint a second time
it did not this is a case that the trump
campaign was never going to win but it's
interesting because
this might be one of the rare instances
where a particular lawyer's bad
lawyering actually made things
worse and it appears that that's what
happened with some of rudy's
admissions or at least his lawyering and
the third circuit court of appeals
in an opinion authored by a trump
appointee points out
that the only issue that the trump
campaign appealed on is this very narrow
issue of whether the trial court abused
its discretion
in not allowing them to amend the
complaint yet again and
for reasons that we already covered that
was really not going to win
anyway but in many ways the trump
campaign has
given up a whole bunch of different
issues that they could have raised and
just barreled forward with this one
narrow issue that's not going to change
the day and the third circuit court of
appeals basically comes as close as they
ever will to saying that this was all
based on the chewbacca defense in the
first place
where this court actually compares the
trump effort to alchemy stating
seeking to turn those state law claims
into federal ones the campaign claims
discrimination
but its alchemy cannot transmute lead
into gold
the campaign never alleges that any
ballot was fraudulent or cast by any
illegal voter
it never alleges that any defendant
treated the trump campaign or its votes
worse than it treated the biden campaign
or its votes calling something
discrimination does not make it so the
second amended complaint still suffers
from these
core defects so granting leave to amend
would have been
futile that does not make sense and now
the case is out but
obviously they can try to appeal to the
supreme court the third circuit court of
appeals has to hear the appeal no matter
what
but the supreme court is based on what's
called certiorari so
it's completely up to the supreme court
whether they will want to hear any part
of this particular case
and a 99 chance that the supreme court
rejects this out of hand
or if they do take it up it will
probably be a quick dismissal
so the trump campaign is probably out of
luck here and there's not a whole lot
that the supreme court could do even if
they picked up this case
now at the same time i saw a lot of
people being worried about the decision
in
kelly versus pennsylvania in that
lawsuit several republican candidates
and voters filed a lawsuit against
pennsylvania
the general assembly and the governor
and the secretary of state the lawsuit
was to block the state from certifying
the election results and ask the courts
to
exclude mail-in ballots from the
certified results or alternatively to
direct the general assembly to choose
its own electors
and the media reported that the
commonwealth court
stopped certification of the votes which
actually is not true the court's order
merely said
quote to the extent that there remains
any further action to perfect
certification of the result of the 2020
general election
for presidents and vice president
certification was enjoined
but there was no further action needed
to perfect certification it already was
certified and on top of that the
pennsylvania supreme court has already
vacated the order
this kelly versus pennsylvania suit is
pretty much much ado about nothing
and the big clowning continued in
another case in wood versus
raffensberger
this is a case where the provided
evidence was asserting all kinds of
voter fraud in different counties in
michigan that were actually in
minnesota and the court issued a
complete smackdown denying the
tro the temporary restraining order and
went so far as to say that the plaintiff
in that case
was using authority that was no longer
good law that the 11th circuit had
expressly abrogated that holding and yet
the plaintiff was using that as a reason
why the court should act here and the
court also said that the case was barred
by latches which is an issue in a lot of
these different election cases the
the doctrine of latches is an
unnecessary delay so
if you delay too long in bringing your
case and the circumstances change then
you shouldn't be allowed to go forward
with your particular lawsuit and when
you're talking about election law
so many of these laws regarding the way
that the votes are going to be counted
or the way that the election is going to
go forward those laws existed before the
election
so it's not fair that you get to hang
back wait to see the results of the
election and then claim that the
election itself was improper and the
court here does go so far as to say that
latches should apply because you you
can't say that you don't like the
results of the election and then
claim that you should disregard the
election entirely after the fact when
the laws have been there the whole time
and then on top of that the trump
campaign is voluntarily dismissing a
whole bunch of cases including purkle
versus wolf
brooks vs mahoney ball vs whitmer legend
horse versus piochor
and donald trump versus benson and
finally that brings us to the almost
mythical claims of sydney powell we
talked earlier about how she was
basically kicked out of the trump
campaign's
lawsuit strategy but she came back in
force filing a lawsuit in michigan
called king vs whitmer
as well as one in georgia called pearson
versus kempt and
here these are some of the most typo
ridden
pleadings i've ever seen in my entire
life and that's just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to
the procedural and substantive defects
of these particular cases
here they're using evidence from
affidavits from other cases that have
already been rejected they
try to use a star witness whose name
and background have been redacted
without trying to file anything under
seal
without going into the weeds a federal
civil procedure that's
not how you would protect someone's
identity not that this is even a place
where you could protect
someone's identity from a public filing
in this particular case
and these lawsuits are likely to suffer
the exact same fates as all of the other
trump campaign lawsuits that we've
already seen
they're pleading fraud without
particularized allegations in fact they
are seeking relief from the courts
that's already moot or impossible for
the courts to grant
they're saying that simply choosing the
dominion
software was a violation of the
constitution
they suffer from standing issues they
fail to allege
a whole bunch of causes of action it's
just
more nonsense based on facts that
appear to be completely made up and of
course this is happening while the
states are just simply going on with
business as usual where
the crucial states are just certifying
their elections and selecting the
electors to go to the electoral college
including nevada michigan pennsylvania
and georgia
all of those states have already
certified their results and
while it's not impossible to undo that
it would be extremely difficult
and those actions make these lawsuits
and a lot of the other trump campaign
lawsuits to the extent that they exist
anymore
moot and extremely likely to be
dismissed by the courts it seems that
they're dismissing their cases because
the allegations
of grand conspiracies never materialized
sadly
we never saw the kraken that sidney
powell promised us because
the kraken never existed or maybe the
legal kraken was the friends that we
made along the way because
everything that sidney powell has been
complaining about has been completely
made up from the dominion voting
machines to the conspiracy that the
republican governor threw the election
for the democrats
everything that she said was complete
fiction and not really even believable
fiction
and since no reasonable person believed
sydney powell she really could have
benefited from sabbah to hear skillshare
class
writing authentic fiction how to build a
believable character
now that pal has been fired she'll have
lots of time to focus on that fiction
novel
the scarlet barrister but sabah to hear
skillshare class walks you through her
personal process for crafting authentic
and believable characters it's packed
with exercises prompts and tried and
true techniques
this class will teach you how to create
real and nuanced characters that feel
like they could walk right off the page
and not into a conspiracy theory and of
course the best place to learn anything
is on skillshare
skillshare as you know is an online
learning community that has tens of
thousands of classes on everything like
illustration creative writing
business productivity music you name it
the first 1000 legal eagles will get a
free premium membership to skillshare
when you click on the link in the
description
plus after the trial ends skillshare is
still way more affordable than most
online learning platforms with
plans starting at less than ten dollars
a month plus clicking on the link in the
description
really helps out this channel